the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so my question is sort of twofold sort
of goes back on it sort of goes back on
some of other things we've discussed the
recent elections so I've recently been
following some of your stuff and there's
evidence that suggests that you sort of
predicted rise from the campaign about
seven years ago and I'm sort of curious
what what what was so different about
this election I presume you've seen the
rise of funny presidential candidates
over the years and I'm sort of curious
to understand what what sort of prompted
that that speculation he's under my
question sort of it's looking more so
into the future so as we discussed
America is probably more polarized and
it's I guess sort of been in the past
and there's sort of this idea that the
clustering of like-minded Americans is
tearing us apart
so where do you see the future of this
nation going
well I mean there are many special
factors in the United States societies
are different but notice that what
happened in this election what actually
happened in the 2016 election is that
the mainstream establishment
institutions were basically destroyed
the two major phenomena in this election
where the Sanders campaign among the
Democrats and the Trump campaign among
the Republicans and they were both
anti-establishment and the voters went
that way the if you take a look at poll
polling results you can see it I mean
anger and contempt for institutions is
just phenomenal you know you ask people
and polls that they have any what do you
think about Congress you know 90 percent
say they have you all thrown out you
know in fact about the only institution
that has any respect is the military
because you're taught you know somehow
the military's defending us from those
one but and the same is true in your
take a look at the French election a
couple days ago the two candidates were
Outsiders the political parties barely
participated knock on the pen are from
outside the mainstream that has run
Europe for 50 years the center right and
center-left parties are gone same thing
happened in England with brexit same
things happening in other European
countries we're seeing a phenomenon all
over the world Western world in which
the centrist you know center left center
right institutions are under attack
people are angry about them they hate
them they think they're not working for
us
and they're right that's the effect of
the neoliberal programs we're all
subjected to the same socio-economic
programs they've had a similar effect
everywhere they've led to stagnation
decline undermining of public services
inability the Reagan slogan into the
state is the problem not the solution
let's turn it over to private tyrannies
which make it worse that's happening
bits and pieces that are happening
everywhere so it happened in the United
States and its own particular way but
but notice that it's two directions
it's Sanders and Trump and I think in
many ways they were appealing to the
same sentiments and they could even
converge you know a lot of the poppy if
you if you look at what people believe
the policies that they favor it's a lot
of its shared so for example you know
across the population all the way over
to the Tea Party people think there
ought to be higher taxes on the rich
probably a majority of the population
thinks they're out of the national
health care no in fact I support for
nationally guaranteed self health care
has been so high over the years that
sometimes it's almost hard to believe so
in the late Reagan years for example
about seventy percent of the population
I thought that guaranteed national
health care ought to be in the
Constitution because this is an obvious
demands about 40% of the population
thought it already was in the
Constitution nobody knows what's in the
Constitution just everything good must
be in the Constitution since this is so
obviously good it must be in the
Constitution there's right at the
present of the most recent polls show
someone over fifty percent supporting a
nice
health care when Obama's Affordable Care
Act was being pushed through at first
there was one of the proposals one of
the parts of it was what was called a
public option which means you could
choose if you wanted to be part of a
government health care program about
two-thirds of the population favored
that but it was just thrown out without
discussion the and in fact Fito
case-by-case there's a lot of similarity
in the attitudes about social political
issues not necessarily cultural issues
but social political issues among parts
of the population that appear to be
extremely polarized it's very
interesting in England right now if he
followed the Jeremy Corbyn has kind of a
little bit like Sanders is bitterly
attacked by the media I mean just
including the liberal media like The
Guardian and by the parliamentary Labour
Party meaning the you know the guys who
sort of the elites who run the party
among they just came out with a I
happened to be in England a couple days
ago as I was reading the British press
they they just came out with their the
Labour Party with their program which
was just lambaste it by the media you
know crazy lunatic insane it'll destroy
the Labour Party at the same time polls
came out asking people it was
independent about the the components of
the program they were all very popular
very strong support among the population
for the elements of the program but
attack and on the party that's proposing
them in a particular on cordovan these
are you know the serious activism and
organizing could overcome this I mean
you're fighting a link elements who have
their own
image of the way they want society to go
and in fact you know there's quite a lot
of interesting things going on a lot of
it has this stuff that you guys might be
interested in has to do with data are
vestee there's a company called
Cambridge analytics I think which is run
by some ultra-right billionaires Peter
Thiel the guy who owns PayPal and a
bunch of other things Robert Mercer
who's a hedge fund manager multi
billionaire a couple of others what
they've been doing and this essentially
gave the election to Trump is extremely
careful data analysis there's a ton of
data now from Facebook and other things
about people's personal preferences and
attitudes and you know feelings and are
you depressed you know all kinds of
things and what they're doing is looking
carefully at this data and analyzing it
to see if you can find small numbers of
people in particular areas who can be
who are vulnerable to one or another
form of manipulation and what they're
doing is trying to say look if they're
kind of tend to be liberal try to get
them to get so disillusioned that they
won't vote and if they tend to be say
traditionally conservative maybe
religious or whatever I try to get them
to do you know reach them individually
in ways which will increase the
probability that they'll vote for the
right-wing this has small effects but
the elections are won on very small
effects like Trump's as you know Trump
lost the popular vote but by a couple of
million but in particular counties that
made the difference a couple of hundred
thousand votes shifted the election in
England brexit was the same
tomatoe about maybe 600,000 votes in all
countries this week you know these
companies using a lot of complicated
data processing and statistics and so on
working on ways to try to control the
electoral process I mean this is way
more important than any of the nonsense
about the Russian hacking that's all
garbage but this stuff is real and it's
that's right in front of our eyes it's
the people we know you know MIT students
going off to work in these things and it
has a big effect on controlling formal
democratic systems they feel this is
Steve Bannon this is his image of how
you control the world you know these are
people who are influential they have
tons of money they deeply reactionary
and they have a fee they want to use
modern data processing
you know big data statistical analysis
and so on to see if you can just find
ways of swinging elections by going
after individual vulnerabilities using
the massive data that people provide
through Google and Facebook and all of
this stuff I mean Google and the rest of
music for advertisers so that
advertisers can go after you
individually and say you know like you
know you try to get a book on Amazon and
they suggest ten other books you ought
to buy because they've got so much
information on you that they think may
be way back and sort of getting to sell
this one that's going on all the time
but here it's right in the middle of the
political system and it's really
significant quite unlike the Russian
hacking story this is real and it's not
very far from us facts happening right
here you know there are things that can
be done about that
like exposing it for one thing these
should be live issues I think among
students do we want to devote our lives
to destroying democracy maybe